one of the most inspiring stories that I
have from my journey around the world
was when I met her a chap called Tony I
was in Pittsburgh and I had nowhere to
stay I'd asked lots of people to help me
and and they'd said no which is fine I
mean I had no expectations for people to
help
I spoke to Tony I said can I stay with
you and he looked at me and he said I'm
homeless I'm sorry but I'm homeless I
felt a lot of shame but then he said to
me you know what if you want to come and
stay with me I'll protect you I'll help
I'll feed you I'll give you some
blankets and that'll be all good and I
was in just total shock and I said to
him are you being serious he's like
absolutely so I spent the night on the
streets of Pittsburgh with one of the
kindest men I've ever met
here was a man that had nothing
literally nothing he fed me he protected
me and he showed me and opened up my
heart and he was such a kind man and
what he did was he showed me that true
wealth is not in our wallets but it's in
our hearts he was a man that had nothing
like I said again nothing and he gave me
everything and he changed my life truly
Tony changed my life he changed my life
he opened up my heart and he made me
realize it's about human connection
that's where the true beauty of life is
human connection not necessarily what we
have in our wallets you can be the
richest man in the world and still be
the poorest man in the world you can be
the poorest man in the world and be the
richest man
you